you hey this is a decibel ometer you
hear my voice now that is at this many
decibels and I'm gonna see how loud the
things in my life are alright this is
the oh [ __ ] what did I do
what it excuse me oh [ __ ] it's a bomb
huh
all right she's still good so I'm just
gonna put this it's not the cord the
cord ain't long enough it's currently
1:28 its 1:28 I need to go to some place
to get a longer cable so that I can
extend this bad boy okay so uh I'll see
you when I see you when I get there okay
see ya I'm gonna crack open the window
ah [ __ ] okay so according to my meter
I've got 16 miles left I'm pretty sure I
can get there anyway here I go
I used to come to this Walmart when I
was younger because it was a 24-hour
Walmart and I would just walk around the
aisles but this Walmart right here is
[ __ ] closed why did you change why
did you change how loud is my outrage at
this why did you change why have you
changed why are you not what I remember
no one's here
I've never seen a Walmart parking lot
with no one here away [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
hey let me show you how quiet it is in
this parking lot how close down it
actually is so I'm coming so stealth
update they have parked over there
and so long as I maintain a certain
level of stealth if I keep it under 70
DB I think I will be just fine they
shouldn't notice my presence [ __ ]
they're trying the door they're trying
the door they are trying the door you
brave son of a [ __ ] you brave bastard
they're trying the door oh [ __ ] nob
disappointment reigns let me see how a
lot is disappointment is
it's really sad my gas is on low I've
got 16 miles left on the of the
assumptive range so I think that means I
could get to the next Walmart that is
open 24 hours I came to this one because
I was nostalgic about it like when I
used to live here in Cincinnati I used
to just go for drives all the time if I
ever needed to clear my head for
anything I would just go out and on 275
it's this big interstate loop and I
would just loop it over and over and
over again and I could do that for hours
just because I had so much [ __ ] going on
in my head that I needed to think
through and it takes me a long time to
think through spots like the solace it
brought late nights just driving around
and my windows have fogged up like crazy
people go think I'm [ __ ] in here am i
funny
I'm about to get artsy BAM
put this baby into Lowell let's get out
here oh [ __ ]
okay so emergency stop light update oh
[ __ ] it's green oh [ __ ] and it's gone so
I'm dumb [ __ ] dead dog okay update
red light update I'm at zero [ __ ]
zero I'm at a stoplight but I'm a nice
cake there's no there's no gas stations
here I could've sworn I remember their
beef one it's been a while since I've
been here but pretty I thought
where is Rick I need gas I got Sam's
Club yes I don't have that Sam's Club
card to do I can't even get your gas I
don't know go for it you know the choice
are you [ __ ] kidding me
are you for excuse you wait hang on how
loud is my outrage right now excuse you
why why have you closed your pumps to
the public all right so bingo Bongo I
found one it's it's literally right
around the corner okay car didn't start
up yes the rest
discretions dispenser closed excuse you
dispenser you can't read it but it says
dispensary Billings [ __ ] that what
the [ __ ] can't show if there's not a gas
station open here [ __ ] found one it
spread across that intersection it says
24 hours on it
excuse see if she starts up again she
sure does she sure does but how long I
don't know we got it we got to go I know
I'm low on fuel you don't did tell me
also the pump started beeping randomly I
have no idea what it was beeping as if
someone was punching codes but there's
there's no one there there was no one I
swear to God I thought someone pulled up
on the other side
punching codes turns out that was not
the case it was a [ __ ] ghost
I think my decibel lammeter would have
been on I would have known it was a
[ __ ] ghost my lights aren't on okay
there she is there Oh [ __ ] green
everyone run across your buttholes for
me it's about to get it's about to get
tweaked oh there we go
it is open as hell it is open when they
get a quick quality check of the ghosts
Oh double bonus um they had a car blog
with a four foot cable four feet of
decibel ometer this might be the lamest
thing I've ever said you know loud as me
opening this four feet
I look like four feet yeah actually does
okay look this bad boy in there that is
longer than the fan plug sorry you got
to die real quick No
wink and we back up that's good
okay cool now I've got an established
place for you and just realize I'm gonna
get pulled over because this looks like
a speed radar or something or if a cop
sees that they're going to be so
suspicious I didn't mention this this is
a Meijer gas station 24 hours was there
for me Sam's Club is owned by Walmart
and they were not there for me so why
would I go there when I am literally
right next to my ear that's the next
apartment
that's a bolometer what do you think
should I go to the Walmart or should I
go to the Meijer thanks buddy okay
update I realized I'm dumb the whole
point of going to Walmart or Meyer was
to get a flood thing I just got that
from the gas station
so incoming you like that your clothes
your clothes you know it's funny when I
was in that Meijer I it has the exact
same layout as the one I went to as a
kid the one in Milford and it was so
weird that I was taken all the way back
to back-to-school shopping with my dad
cuz they had school supplies set up in
the aisle which is really depressing cuz
it's only the end of June
but back-to-school is already a concern
I don't know it was just weird trip down
memory lane and nice cool you didn't see
what happened until now Oh [ __ ]
selfie stick baby I could probably pop
that up yeah there we go
I don't know what the I don't know what
the max for this bad boy is it might be
like $9.99 but I know that the
the decibel scale is logarithmic so a
noise that would register 999 on the
decibel scale would probably be powerful
enough to destroy the planet so I think
that I'm safe I got some fireworks
poppers all right so this if that's my
old high school good ol Milford High
anyway that's how I were fear we heard
to test noise forget to how my ears was
that one 117 did that pika
oh alright maybe doing that in a
confined space is a bad idea that hurt
my ears the Milford High School Eagle
marching band that is the band that I
was in I was a part of this band I did
the band thing so I brought my oh yeah
yeah
decibel ometer this is my old trumpet
but there's you don't know I play
trumpet cuz I'm awesome this is to you
Milford marching band it's 3:45 a.m. and
I'm doing noise test that's only a true
trumpet would that's just the mouthpiece
at 1:21 that's the records so far that's
even louder than the pop that's a good
test and this is what you call a mute I
don't know why they invented these they
clearly don't work all right good test
moving on apparently I can't go this way
instruction
pretty quiet there's deer how loud are
you this is the University of Cincinnati
this is where I did not graduate
engineering school so great I like
revisiting old memories you know I like
the nostalgia slightly noise here bye
goodbye you see off the box back home I
want this thing to peak I have no idea
what the peak is peak damn it oh it
hurts my ears why does it make you
what's your what's your lip
what's his power level oh I feel like I
feel like three would make me go deaf
let's do three I'm gonna open the window
just because he's gonna be loud and I
don't want to kill myself here we go I
have no idea what the actual peak of
this thing is there's some like speaker
holes here so I'm gonna speak softly
into its ass
they say softly and then I'm gonna
scream into this thing's ass almost
screaming to your ass
oh oh that's the money oh there's this
tiny little thing
right there that's I think that I think
that's the mic 132 baby 130 oh it is now
5:30 6:00 a.m. I was born on June 28
1989 at 5:30 6:00 a.m. I am now
officially 30 years old and I know
that's not technically true because of
time zones I was born in Hawaii and I'm
in Cincinnati but this feels right the
Sun is just barely coming up I spent all
night because I wanted to see it I
wanted to be here for it and I wanted to
go into my 30s you know with eyes wide
open kind of like knowing how it's gonna
be because when I went into my 20s I had
no clue who I was or who I wanted to be
I had no idea and I only started this
YouTube thing when I was 22 I was just
about to turn 23 in a few months but I
was 22 and I still had no idea who I was
or what I wanted to be or even if I
liked who I was but the only difference
between those two moments is that when I
was 22 and I served my youtube channel I
wanted to figure out who I was
and so much of my 20s has been defined
by this like doing videos on YouTube
making every day count you know kind of
figuring out who I am
day by day and it hasn't always been
easy like ups and downs you know I I was
thinking that I was gonna have like some
of this grand wisdom the moment I turned
30 I was gonna be like ah yes I'm 30 now
I know how the world works if I had to
boil down everything I've learned about
figuring out who I am over the past
seven plus years or so is that life is
not about milestones even though it may
seem like it is life is not about
hitting a number and then being like ah
here are all the new skills you've
learned you're wise now you you know
things that's not the way it is you know
just like everything in life if you want
something you have to work for it if you
want to know who you are you have to
work for it
if you want to like who you are you have
to work for it and you got to work on
you and that is the number one thing
that I've worked on over the past ten
years all of my 20s has just been me
figuring out who I am and going into my
30s I have a good grasp on Who I am and
I am just eternally grateful for the
opportunities that I have and the
ability to do what I want to do and the
ability to take the time that it took to
figure out who I am and anyway I can't
leave it at just that cuz that's vapid
and self aggrandizing so I want to Erica
yeah okay alright and I
hi-yah hi-yah one last step - ah
[ __ ] I got one last test to do a little
uh a little birthday test
I got a confetti cannon this is gonna
make a mess cuz this thing is huge this
thing is cuz I got these tiny I saw
these tiny little party poppers you guys
know this one ah but that then I saw
this big big mom but so this may be
really loud outdoor use only only
suitable for adults well I am officially
an adult now that's for damn sure
hold firm twist bottom I might go deaf
here ha happy birthday oh my god hey
happy birthday guys well happy birthday
to me happy birthday to everyone else
that also birthday it is but most
importantly this guy right here
pretty good and also we figured out how
loud I was loud so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always in
the next video bye bye